In 2006, two unlikely friends became the heroes of Radiator Springs.
But on their next big road trip,...
...they're not only racing across the world,...
Wish me luck.
You go get 'em, buddy.
Welcome to the inaugural running of the World Grand Prix.
...they're racing to save the world.
No one can stop us.
Finn McMissile, British Intelligence.
Tow Mater, average intelligence.
Welcome to Tokyo International Airport.
Listen, this isn't Radiator Springs.
These Americans are clearly master spies.
Oh, you've gotta be joking!
Go, McQueen!
10-4 Mater.
I'm on approach.
Roger that.
There he is!
He's getting away.
Hang on!
Yeah, go!
Whoa! I knew I should have done carry-on.
Cars 2.
Ka-chow!
Sorry, lady.